[Music]
Jordan thank you so much for giving us
some time again I'm in Sydney you're in
Kentucky yes I am I'm there as part of
my 12 rules for life tour which is I
think expanding to hit about maybe 80
cities something like that goodness well
that was very keen to have a follow-up
chat after the conversation that you and
I had together when you're in Sydney and
in particular to frame that for people
who might be listening this conversation
at that time I had not seen you in front
of a live audience
the evening of that conversation after
that conversation I had that opportunity
at Chatswood one of the seven talks that
you gave in Australia put together by
Sam McClelland from from Melbourne every
one of them are sellout I have to say I
don't know whether the biggest issue for
me is what I learnt by watching that all
the questions that arise out of it but
the first thing I'd say is I was
concerned at the time that you and I had
had a very long conversation that it
might be too long for people when we put
it on the website and you said no John
it won't be young people especially are
hungry for content put it all up there
they will listen to it you're absolutely
right young people looking for content
it's it is absolutely amazing yes well I
mean some of the big YouTube stars like
Joe Rogan they're they're constantly
putting out three-hour podcasts and
people listen to all of them long-haul
truckers listen to them and guys driving
forklifts and and young people and and
couples and like there's a massive
hunger for real for ready for
high-quality educational material it
shouldn't be underestimated and I mean
one of the things that seems to be the
case with these people on YouTube that
are making a splash let's say in this
alternate media format is that they
fully they have full respect for the or
the intelligence of their audience and
they don't pull any punches in terms of
content or length yeah well that's where
they come back to that but but as I say
you know it's just extraordinary I pull
up in a fuel station out in a country
town near where I live and somebody gets
out of the car
next to me father of about 35 I suppose
he looks at me and he just says straight
up before even says hello
he said I've just been listening to you
and Jordan Peterson having a
conversation and everywhere I go now
that's what people say so thank you for
the opportunity you made the comment
there though there for every youtube
visit they'd be up to 11 podcasts I
think that's what you said
well the podcast market is absolutely
exploding and you're actually sitting
seeing this start to affect book
publishing because audio books have
become extraordinarily popular and
people are discovering that they can use
their found time when they're commuting
or exercising or walking or doing dishes
whatever to engage themselves in high
quality um
well high quality educational material
books and podcasts and so that's a real
revolution it and it really is a
revolution so these are the people young
people too you know instead of listening
to music which is really something
because musics being a predominant
cultural force for a very long time so
it's an it's an amazing technological
revolution and I really appreciate it or
a conversation by the way I think we had
a great conversation I enjoyed it
immensely and it seems to me that this
is a sort of modern version and and I
think this is terrific if I'm
understanding it correctly or the old
idea where people who have perhaps had
another great formal education had
access to good quality literature and so
forth put together by whether it was
penguin or what was it every man's book
so every everyday books whatever they
were called
even Reader's Digest to make that
education that learning the classics and
so forth available widely and now this
is a modern version of it perhaps and I
think what's happening with the
mainstream mean that they underestimate
the moral quality of their viewers they
underestimate their intelligence they
underestimate their persistence and
they've also become quite manipulative
in their use of editing and and message
massaging spin really and the other
thing that's really good about these
sorts of conversations is that what you
see is what you get their bare bones
they're they're not high-tech while they
are and their highest tech in some sense
but not on the production end or the
editing end so people can trust them
and they're genuine conversations
they're not designed to craft the
message or anything like that they're
not manipulative and and that's a big
deal YouTube YouTube particularly
doesn't respond well to manipulation as
far as I can tell well I enjoyed that
conversation enormously I've been
stunned by the response it's gone very
very widely as you know both on your
site and on mine but to come back to
that day later that day you gave one of
the talks of the set one of the seven
that you gave in Australia Chatswood and
I was very kindly allowed to compare it
for you and one thing that 19 years in
public life taught me is to have a bit
of a look at your audience and summarize
them it was a pretty amazing experience
the first thing that happened was that
you walked on before you said a word
you've got a standing ovation though
that that's something unheard of in this
country but they did 90 minutes talk
they gave you another standing ovation
you left came for a few minutes came
back on took 30 minutes of questions and
again they responded in the same way let
me just say a couple of things about
that audience I was firstly I've got to
say pretty heavily impacted as I looked
out there and recognized that there was
an enormous hunger to hear what you had
to say even though your message was
perhaps best described as tough love you
weren't ginger in them up with a soft
story you were really pushing you were
really challenging them the second thing
that struck me is that I've said many
times since I reckon 50% of the people
in that room that night were young
Australian men under the age of probably
35 the third thing that struck me was
that that was a was a cross section I
would say many of them were University
students but all university graduates
but many many were not and the fourth
thing that just goes back to something
you said a moment ago they knew what you
were saying and you're a clinical
psychologist and a highly educated
person to suggest that they didn't
understand would be very patronizing
they got what you're on about
oh definitely there's there's no doubt
about that I mean there those lectures
aren't interesting unless you understand
them and there's just no doubt that
that's happening you know I think one of
the most
that psychologists have made especially
the more popular ones over the last
three or four decades is to try to
convince people that they're okay the
way they are it's like the self-esteem
movement you know you should love
yourself the way they you are you should
feel good about yourself the way you are
and that's actually not a very
optimistic message for people because
people are generally sensible enough to
not be particularly satisfied with the
way that they are they want to be who
they could be they want to have
something noble to aim at and and and so
I I make that case very strong that
you're you should more but aligned and
on board with who you can be then with
who you are and that who you can be
isn't a person who has endless rights or
or or as the member of a privileged or
under privileged group it should be who
you should be should be an individual
who's willing to take on full
responsibility for the for the
catastrophe of existence and for the
malevolence that's part of it and see I
think people are responding to that
first of all because everyone who has
any sense knows that life is a tragic
business and that everyone is
susceptible to betrayal and malevolence
on their own part and and as a
consequence of the actions of others
that's our existential predicament and I
think people also know in a very deep
sense that the antidote to that isn't
security or safety and it's not envy or
bitterness it's the willingness to try
to work to make the world a better place
to start with yourself to take
responsibility for yourself and then to
take responsibility for your family and
then to take responsibility for your
community and everyone knows that the
people they admire are exactly the
people that do that and we also all know
that that's what gets you out of bed on
a rough morning it's that you've got
something important and vital to do and
it's not an easy thing it isn't
necessarily even something that makes
you happy it's something that's
meaningful and necessary to fight back
against the tragedy and the malevolence
of the world and people know that deeply
it's deeply rooted inside their their
souls I would say and a call to that is
very meaningful for people including me
you know I include myself and my
audience
like I'm lecturing to them precisely I'm
having a conversation with them about
how we can step the world right and we
are setting it right things are getting
better very rapidly around the world and
we can really push that forward in the
decades to come if we if we made a
conscious effort and so I think this is
a very exciting message for people one
of the things that I'd say about
Australians is as I got the world's best
bulldust detectors they recognise
authentic authenticity very quickly and
if you're not authentic they won't
listen so I think in part they are
responding if I can pay you a compliment
by the fact that you weren't talking
about you you were talking about us you
were addressing where we are all
together as human beings and in a way it
was as though you were saying to get to
the good news you've actually got to go
through what might be called the valley
of death you've got to face yourself
you've got to be realistic about
yourself in the world that you live in
and I saw those put young people it was
almost as though they were saying we're
sick to death of a therapy cup a culture
that offers us sort of to relieve to
everyone there's a there's a dictum that
Carl Jung derived from the great
alchemists in the circle in this
infinite or and it means what you most
want will be found where you least want
to look what you most need will be found
where you least want to look and that
people know that you know everyone knows
they are tired of naive optimism let's
say and not optimism because optimism
doesn't have to be naive and they know
perfectly well that the way to set
themselves right is to take careful
stock of themselves and to pay very
careful attention to the errors that
they know they're making and to and to
grow up and to mature and to and to
adopt the responsibilities of a
forthright citizen and I think people
are sick to death of too much discussion
of rights and and too much discussion of
self-esteem and all that all that all
that discussion that goes along with
what everyone owes you it's like it's
just not helpful to people because it
isn't your rights that give you meaning
in life and you need a meaning to set
against the tragedy and every
knows that the way that you find that
meaning it's by adopting responsibility
obviously for yourself you gotta take
care of yourself your family I mean you
want to be a good person to your parents
you want to be a good person to your
siblings and your children clearly and
you have to bear some responsibility for
your community and if you're really
firing on all cylinders you do all those
things at the same time you know and and
I do believe and I tell people I do
believe that the world is the tragic and
malevolent place in many many ways but
that the way forward through that is is
to do everything you can to put yourself
on the side of what's good and to aim
high and that that's where you get the
dignity that enables you to bear life
without becoming corrupt and everyone
knows this is true who's gonna argue
with that having found yourself and
having any of your like and being
realistic about yourself and recognizing
we were talking about this last time the
dividing line between good and evil it's
not between black and white or whatever
captor and jailer or man and woman it's
somewhere across every human heart
having recognized that you can then go
on and help build a stronger fairer more
just more humane society rather than
what seems to be the way people approach
it at the moment so that somehow rather
your society can fix your problems yes
well that's it I mean for young people
in particular it's kits are actually a
very depressing message for young people
to hear that it's time for them to get
involved in political activism because
any young person who has any sense knows
perfectly well if they're especially if
they're 18 they're so 19 years old is
they don't know a damn thing you know
they haven't started a business they
haven't started a family they don't have
a permanent relationship they're not
educated they don't have any experience
and for someone to come and say well
you're in a position to change the world
is nothing but a way of disenchanting
them with adult wisdom it's like you're
not ready to change the world you've got
a lot to learn but you can learn it and
in learning it you'll become much more
powerful and much more charismatic and
much more articulate and much more wise
and sensible and that's the way forward
to being much more than you are and
young people
when you're 18 and you have 60 years of
life ahead of you what you want to hear
above all else is that there's way more
of you yet to come because what else has
anything with those 60 years so it's
it's a message it's a harsh message
because it says well you're not
everything you could be but it's a
deeply optimistic message because it's
because the idea is that you could be
way more than you are
incomparably more than you are and I do
believe that and what's so fun about
this is that people keep telling me that
people keep telling me that it's true
you know I have people endless people I
got one kid come up to me the other day
it was so fun he said a year and a half
ago I had just got out of jail and I was
homeless and he said I started listening
to your lectures and I just I got
married this year I have a child and I
just bought my apartment it's like wow
man good work you know you did that in a
year and a half and you know I was in LA
the other about a month ago and you know
this I was in a rough part of LA
downtown LA near the Apollo Theater and
I'd given a talk there my wife and I
were walking down the street this car
pick pulled up and then his kid walked
out he was about 19 or so good-looking
Hispanic kid ran over and asked me if I
was dr. Peters and I said yes and he was
all excited he said he'd been watching
my videos for about a year and a half
and they really helped him straighten
out his life he was just smiling away he
said wait a minute wait a minute and he
ran back to his car and he came back out
with his dad and his dad was standing
there you know and they had their arms
around each other and they were just
grinning like mad and the kid said look
I've really put my relationship together
with my father and we're really on board
with this together and they were just
like so happy you couldn't believe it
and that just happens over and over like
it happens I would say four or five
times a day in restaurants or in
airports or while you've been
experiencing that to some degree in
Australia you said and it's it's so good
and the mainstream media that's been
covering what I've been doing you know
they just missed this completely because
everything it seems like everything that
constitutes news in our society has to
be political and group
oriented this isn't political and it's
not group oriented what I'm trying to do
as a good clinical psychologist and
perhaps a good educator and I mean good
striving to be good in the moral sense
is to help people develop as individuals
and they are and it's really working and
it's it's a thrill to be on this tour
because that's all I hear and no one
talks to me about the political issues
or very very rarely and it's all because
I also think that the battle against
collectivists and let's say the battle
against identity politics isn't to be
had in the political realm maybe that's
a secondary issue what the way that you
that you fight for the sovereignty of
the individual is by getting your act
together and and right locally right
where you are and starting to take
advantage of everything that you have in
front of you and and then you do you
know harm our way all you do is make
yourself less bad who what's the harm
not that's a good thing to some extent I
think the battle here is almost one of
statism or collectivism versus
individual liberty
who's going to shape who so you've got
the whole that sort of pushed from the
left identity politics victimhood
policies approaches and what have you we
owe these people what have you so the
state has control and shapes individuals
and helps them forward on the other hand
you have the different view that says no
the state should be shaped by the people
that make up the state you know
Australia is a sum total of individuals
who are Australian and they ought to be
shaping the public square not having the
public square of your local the public
sector shaping them the whole argument
is about what what what's the primary
unit of analysis that's everything
what's the primary unit of analysis and
in the West the primary unit of the
analysis has been the logos and that's
something like Devine individual
consciousness and it's on that ground
that we developed our idea of individual
sovereignty and citizenship and you know
we don't talk about a citizen is someone
who adopts the responsibilities of an
ethical being that's a citizen we don't
talk about that even in schools
tell people that look the meaning in
your life is going to be found it's
gonna be proportionate to the degree
that you take responsibility for
positively shaping your experience and
the experience of the people around you
and this isn't like be good in some in
some week be inoffensive and harmless
sense it's not that at all it's like get
your spine straight get your aggression
integrated pick a heavy goal like a
heavy high goal something you can barely
tolerate lifting and struggle along with
it and that's where you'll find yourself
respect and and people know that it's
it's fun to watch the working-class guys
respond to this too you know because
they know this most of those guys work
like mad you know and they know that
there's nobility in that
and and there is and so it's it's well
I'm people also say well that they're
happy to come to my lectures or even
read the book because I'm helping them
find words to express things that they
already knew to be true and those things
that they know to be true are the
bedrock axioms of our culture and one of
the things we got right in the West was
the idea of the sovereign responsible
individual not the person with rights
and certainly not the person with rights
granted to them by the state that's not
part of the English common law tradition
you're the locus of Rights but but only
in some sense because you're the locus
of ultimate responsibility I guess part
of what I've been trying to tell people
is that there's no difference between
meaning and responsibility they're the
same thing yeah no I understand what
you're saying
now as I looked at that audience I
thought to myself we're doing a lot of
talking about the first world war in
this country 60 thousand Australians
died out of a very small population in
that horrendous event and we celebrate
their bravery those young Anzacs we call
them who went off to Gallipoli and then
to the Western Front and we're involved
in some of the critical battles of the
First World War every year Australians
turn out in extraordinary numbers and
more and more young Australians turn out
to if you like pay tribute to their
courage and as I looked out across that
audience I thought there's a lot of
people here that I'd willingly
or I would choose to be with in the
trenches they are essentially people who
want to be to use the word you did just
a moment ago noble to the best of their
ability but they live in a culture
somehow that says no that's all nonsense
that's not where you ought to go and it
seemed to me that they're deeply
resenting and deeply keen to reject that
approach look here's here's what it is
so there's this idea that that's pushed
very hard in the Universities by the
postmodern neo-marxist types and before
anybody objects I know perfectly well
that technically speaking post-modernism
and neo-marxist neo Marxism aren't
commensurate but it doesn't stop people
from from joining them together
ideologically but in any case the idea
is that the West is fundamentally an
oppressive patriarchy which it isn't
it's hardly an oppressive society
because every society is partly
oppressive and flawed but fundamentally
the West is not an oppressive patriarchy
and but if you by that line then the
next thing that comes along is that
anything you do that contributes to that
patriarchy is also oppressive and
tyrannical and so that's extraordinarily
demoralizing for people who are trying
to make their way in the world because
they're trying to hoist their
responsibilities up on their shoulders
and become competent contributing adults
and they're criticized to death for
being oppressive tyrants and so there's
a conflation of competence with tyranny
and you can't do anything to anyone
that's more demoralizing that you know
than that Nietzsche said if you want to
punish someone punish them for their
virtues and so they're tired of that
it's so demoralizing you know like it
appeals to the part of each man let's
say and each woman for that matter who
wants to avoid responsibility because
you can rationalize it and say well I'm
not gonna take responsibility because
that just makes me a tyrant and an agent
of the patriarchy but that's a-- that
sort of thing leads people down at
toolpath and I've seen that my my
friends and in my clinical practice so
instead we say look like our culture has
problems every culture does and it needs
everyone everyone has to be awake so
that we don't slip at every level of our
social being into some
like a blind authoritarianism but the
way that that happens is by waking up
and taking responsibility once again for
yourself and your family and your
community and that that and that's Noble
which is a word you never hear it's like
a human being has to be a noble creature
to withstand the tragedy of existence
without becoming corrupt and so and that
calls to the best in people and Jordan
just we should wrap up on that part of
it that evening though but there was one
other thing when we came to question
time there were four mics in the room
they lined up 20 deeper deets we got to
seven I think the seventh question was
from a lady who asked a very intelligent
question about what parents bring to
their children and and in particular
were there things that mothers brought
to their children that women do best
and other things that fathers bring to
their children that are best you gave a
very rousing answer the issue of
fathering and as I say there are a lot
of men there I gather that your
audiences of the demographics have
broadened out now but that was a very
young man centric group and you hammered
the importance as I heard it all
fathering
well the the empirical literature on
this is absolutely clear I mean you know
we have this idea that's being pushed
forward that all families are equal it's
like there's a there's a grain of truth
in that in that people who are
struggling mightily to raise their
children properly are worthy of respect
whether there are single or in couples
but the empirical literature is
absolutely clear that that stable intact
for the families with fathers there
produce children who do way better on
almost every possible measure and even
more than that that in communities where
fathers tend to be at home what you know
as part of the stable family the
communities themselves do better even
those kids that don't have fathers at
home so the role of the father is
unbelievably important and the question
is what particular rold as a father plan
I just had a good conversation with
Warren Farrell about that and part of no
part of my research should indicated
that men are particularly
useful in initiating rough-and-tumble
play and play with their children in
general and Farrell extended that by
noting that men could use the
opportunity to play as a reward for
delaying gratification among their
children that's a really big deal
because one of the things you have to do
to help people mature is to teach them
to delay gratification and to sustain
attention and it looks like men that the
pleasure that children get in playing
with their fathers rough and tumble play
but other forms of play as well of
primary reward that can be used to help
children learn to make the proper
sacrifices and regulate their impulses
over the long term so so you know and I
think fathers now of course mothers can
do this too but I think fathers are
because mothers are generally charged
with the fundamental care of infants
there's a tension between that and
encouraging children to step forward out
into the world as as courageous beings
and you know mothers are very very
attached to their infants and their
infants are very fragile it's often hard
for them to make the transition from
primary security provider and caregiver
to forthright encourage er of adventure
and that's certainly something that
fathers can do is it's better to
construe life as an adventure rather
than as an enterprise that's there to
make you feel secure or happy it's a
great adventure and a dangerous one at
that because everyone's life is at stake
in this adventure you know we're
unbelievably tough creatures if we if we
put ourselves out fully okay now you
said something very interesting there
and very important in my view you talked
about empirical evidence in the relation
to the importance of fathering empirical
evidence reason evidence-based
decision-making calm thoughtful
deliberation rather than emotion in
other words the difference between
thinking and feeling seems to me to be
incredibly important we should follow
the facts to where they take us but
we're confronted by it seems to be you
mentioned and you said they're not
related but we tie them together there
you know sort of cultural Marxism and
post-modernism it seems to me the
cultural Marxist will deliberately
distort the truth be
because of their agendas or hide the
truth because of their agendas the post
modernists are fallen into this trap of
if you like moral relativity so what's
good for you is true for you and what's
good for me is true for me even if
they're really painting black as white
and white as black isn't that a problem
it's worse than that in some sense
because it's not even what's true for
you it's true for you and what's true
for me is true for me it's what it's
true for your group is only good for
your group and what's true for my group
is only good for my group and so that
sets us off in in group conflict in a
tribal sort of way you know the the the
real radical types who are swallowed up
by this ideology believe that science
itself is nothing but a Eurocentric
patriarchal construct I mean they
dispense completely with the fact that
scientific discovery has given us this
incredible technological power that's
lifted the entire world out of abject
poverty in a period of about a hundred
and fifty years for that for them for
some reason that doesn't constitute
evidence and so when you bring up
evidence there's hand waving because the
people who dispute this sort of thing
rarely know the details of the
literature they just write it off and
say well that whole scientific
enterprise that's just part of the way
that Eurocentric males dominate and
destroyed the planet it's all power
games for these people there's no
there's no reality at the bottom of it
outside of the power game and so that's
a well that that to me that that that's
a that's a viewpoint that leads
inevitably to tribal conflict that's all
that's all that's what it does know you
might be able to help me I think was
George Orwell who made a reference to an
idea being so utterly stupid that only a
member of the intelligentsia could
believe it no sensible person in the
street would accept it for a moment
there was a bit of there that night I
would have thought you actually made a
comment quite a I thought a very astute
remark that about something that sound
absolutely obvious and then you father
finished it by saying you would have
thought someone in a university
somewhere might have noticed now if I'd
been an academic at any university in
Australia I would have realized that I
needed to wake up to myself because the
audience lifted the roof
the place with their applause they are
highly skeptical about what is happening
now in our educational institutions
there is no other way to read that
audience of a thousand decent
Australians they are very skeptical
about the value for money we're getting
now out of our tertiary education sector
yeah well it's the whole education
sector to I would say increasingly from
kindergarten all the way through
University yeah I think that I'm in very
in creasing lis embarrassed to be a
member of the Academy because of that
like I was reading this book today by a
by a Norwegian called progress it's a
really good book I would highly
recommend it very straightforward and
all it is is a compendium of empirical
facts about how much better the world
has been getting for the last hundred
and fifty years in just every possible
way three hundred thousand people a week
are being hooked to the electrical power
grid right we've reduced we've almost
eliminated starvation throughout the
world except for political reasons and
starvation was a big problem in places
like Sweden and Italy less than a
hundred years ago
Island people our people have access to
fresh water and the fastest growing
economies in the world are in
sub-saharan Africa we're just making
progress progress on every possible
front and everything that people learn
in the education system seems to be
associated with the idea that human
beings are a cancerous growth on the
planet that we're going to hell in a
handbasket and that we're gonna burn
ourselves out in the next 50 years and
die and it'll be our fault too and you
know it's just not the case it's simply
not the case I mean we have problems in
front of us but there's a deep anti
human ethos that permeates that and you
know maybe it's still a hangover from
our pessimism from the Cold War
you know because everyone was truly
terrified for about five decades that we
were gonna put everything to the torch
you know and maybe we still haven't
really recovered from that and it's not
surprising because it was brutal but
reading this book on progress just made
me think again how badly were educated
because people just don't know how much
things are getting better and why free
markets are a huge part of it private
property is a huge part of it and that's
all associated with the idea of the
sovereign individual
and so this really works I mean it's
true that Europe got rich first but
that's only being a hundred and most at
most one hundred and fifty years it's
not even that long it's really since
about 1895 and Europe first but man
China there's no one starving in China
there's no one starving in India you
know Southeast Asia has enough food and
and sub-saharan Africa is growing like
mad and then that we have these we have
these we have our education system that
trumpets that you know we live in a
corrupt patriarchy that we should all
identify with our tribal groups and that
the right way of interviewing history is
victimizer group against victim group
it's like it's no wonder people are
skeptical about it it's a profoundly
anti Western ethos and the thing is
about the West is we got the sovereign
individual right it's right and it's the
responsibility part that's right not the
rights part I mean the rights traits are
necessary but but only the rights are
there so that you couldn't express your
responsibility that's what that's the
whole point
okay well let's come to this issue of
our own almost loathing now of our own
beliefs and values here in Australia now
we're having an extraordinary debate
going on a very wealthy and likable I
knew him well philanthropists called
Paul Ramsey who was very active in the
health center left a very large amount
of money to be made available to set up
an academy for the study of Western
civilization and he wanted it to be done
in one of our major universities now one
of our most acclaimed universities
entered into deep negotiations then the
education union got involved and said no
no this is going to be terrible it'll be
all about European ideas of European
supremacy so that same university has
centers for Islamic studies for
Indigenous Studies they are not
particularly autonomous in the sense
that the university or sorry they're not
particularly controlled it seems by the
university they do pretty much their own
thing but I know you can't have a center
for the study of Western civilization it
will fill us up with all sorts of racist
ideas supremacist ideas this is really
worrying if we can't understand
our own past in fact as a very wise
Asian said here the other day
if you wonder them that want to
understand Asian cultures understand
your your own first well it means to me
it's just first of all you know in some
sense I'm less worried about what's
happening with the universities than I
was because I think that they're going
to destroy themselves completely if they
continue the way they are and that all
that's going to happen is that people
will take the genuine value in the
wisdom of the past and presented in
alternative forms
they'll just steal it out from
underneath the universities I would say
to the philanthropist if the
universities don't want the money then
they should set up an institute on their
own that might very well be a good
course you can go directly to the people
now you know like for now a social
example for me if I want a lecture now I
can lecture on anything I want whenever
I want
with no bureaucratic restrictions and I
have an audience of people who are only
listening because they want to listen
there that's where the university is the
University is where there's an audience
to people who are only listening because
they want to be educated that is the
University the buildings are irrelevant
let's let's build on that from I'm it
because watching this debate unfold in
Australia we're listening your academic
saying ah no no we've got to preserve
our academic integrity and we've we're
here to protect policies of diversity
and inclusiveness and all of those sorts
of things and somebody tartly pointed
out actually we thought they were there
to teach our young people how to think
for themselves primarily that isn't what
they're there for because that's
predicated on the idea that there are
sovereign individuals and that they can
actually think for themselves as
individuals the whole idea here is that
you're not an individual you're the
member of a group that's it and they're
serious about this this isn't a trivial
objection it's a fundamental objection
but I would also say look there's a New
Testament statement don't cast pearls
before swine and you know that usually
has to do with words right don't waste
words of wisdom on those who will not
hear but you could also just look at it
literally if you have pearls and you're
trying to give them to someone
and they won't take them then go find
someone else to give the pearls to if
you're trying to give money to a
university to do something great and
they won't take it it's obvious that
they don't want to do anything great so
don't give them the money it's the wrong
people ok well let's taste this had a
little bit more wisdom you've mentioned
the difference between if you like
knowledge and accumulated cleverness and
what have you and wisdom surely there's
a difference because to go back again to
Chatswood I would say a good chunk of
the people there were not university
educated but they were smart and I would
say they I'd say more they were wise
they were striving for wisdom and that's
where wisdom is wisdom is in the
striving for wisdom and wisdom is
building out wisdom isn't a collection
of facts wisdom is knowledge of how to
conduct yourself in the world so it's a
it's an action it's an existential issue
it's an it's its truth as revealed in
action that's wisdom wisdom also
understands consequences well it's it's
sophisticated in its understanding of
consequences because you think well what
are the consequences and the answer is
well there's the consequences for you
now and for you next week and next month
and five years from now so the
consequences are you and future you so
that's an iterated game but the
consequences are also for your family
now and in the future transfer to your
community now and in the future and
wisdom is the ability to consider all of
those consequences as part of your as
part of what guides your vision and your
and your and your operations in the
world and that's character and then
nobility of character is to take all of
those things into account simultaneously
as I watch the debate I thought to some
extent one of the problems you've got
here is see as Lewis might have pointed
out is pride pride getting in the way of
people having sufficient humility to
recognize that the nonsense they
peddling is simply unconvincing in terms
of what you might call the pub test what
would pass the pub test
out there where people have common sense
and can see when people are being real
and when they're not being real well
it's easy to dispense with that you just
develop sufficient contempt for the
common person and then you don't have to
worry about what they think you know and
then and that's and that's when you
confuse being smart with being wise and
they're not the same thing I don't think
there's any relationship between them in
fact I mean intelligence is a great gift
but it can go terribly wrong and it can
certainly turn into a kind of
intellectual arrogance that's for sure
that blinds you to to your own ignorance
and humility is the antidote to that and
the humility the element of humility
there that's necessary is to understand
that what you don't know is more
important than what you know and so if
you're an ideologue you you dispense
with all doubt because you already know
everything I was gonna say I was
reminded of that friend I Chatswood as
as you probably gathered it had the big
impact on man it was a powerful reminder
to me that for me it seems very
important to recognize it there's a
sense in which the more you learn the
more you realizes you don't know very
much and there's a lot more to learn
yeah well you know being with an
audience can help with it out too
because if you're if you're talking to
an audience you can check to see if your
message is being received you know and
you might say well these people just
can't understand what I have to say it's
like well yeah they probably can if you
if you formulated it carefully and you
actually talk to them individual to
individual which is what I try to do in
my lectures like I'm not talking to the
mob I'm not talking to the group I never
talked to the group when I'm lecturing I
always pick people in the audience and
speak right to them and they reflect the
audit you know they reflect the entire
group but they only reflect it because
the group is made up of individuals like
them so let's just go back to something
you said earlier that ask of me is very
interesting and that is that young
people don't want to be involved in
political activism they want to get
himself sorted out first many of those
young people though I think want to
behave nobly and help build a better
society a stronger civic square if I can
put it that way and good on them that's
terrific that's important they're very
disillusioned with politics and yet we
have to govern our country we have to
make certain
the rules are set if you like and that
we maximize everybody's opportunities to
live in freedom and insecurity when
young people have if you like grounded
themselves and feel ready to act nobly
in the public square what should they do
how can they make a difference they want
to make a difference how do they go
about it Oh
more power to them I think but I think
you know they they start by realizing
they don't know anything and by starting
to learn and then if they learn and work
and discipline themselves the
opportunities to expand will come
naturally because people will notice
them like look if you work with
competent people hyper competent people
one of the things you learn is that
hyper competent people are always
looking for young people to mentor
yeah there's starving and hoping that
someone will come along who who has a
lot of potential and then what they'll
do is offer them an opportunity hmm you
know I keep my eye out at the University
and in my private work as well all the
time for young people who've got
something to contribute
oh you look like you're sharp let's find
out here's a task why don't you go try
this then they come back and knock it
out of the park and you think oh that's
good cuz I got 20 more things here that
need doing that I can't do I've got more
opportunities than I know what to do
with here's another one and so the thing
is is that if you develop your
competence and you discipline yourself
and you start to make that manifest in
any hierarchy that's even vaguely
competent you'll have more opportunities
come your way then you'll know what to
do with so it'll happen organically so
and it it is the way of the world and
well if that isn't happening in the
organization that you're working with
and you're working diligently and you
have your art together then it's time to
find a different organization but
generally speaking most organizations
aren't that corrupt some are interesting
I'd say that Australia's have we worship
youth culture in a way but well things
I've noticed about youth is that
overwhelmingly if I have the opportunity
to tap into the wisdom of an older
person to be mentored they they go
looking for it they're very keen for it
well it's part of the part of the human
proclivity to admire and imitate
you know I mean one of the things that
drives us forward we don't only learn by
facts in fact we hardly learn by facts
at all
we learn by stories and we learn by
imitation and we and may imitate those
we admire and we admire those who are
competent and so if you find someone who
knows what you don't and can operate
effectively in the world in a manner
that you would like to but can't then
you're going to admire them and if you
admire them you're going to open the
door to have them mentor you and I mean
that's that's really fundamental to
human cognition and human psychological
development it's the catalyst for human
development because we're deeply
imitative it's it's the thing that
distinguishes us from other creatures
perhaps even more than even more
fundamentally than language use if I
watch if you know how to do something
and I watch you do it I can learn to do
it without having to go through all the
pain that you had to go through to learn
it it's such a gift
that's why history is so important our
personal history our if you like our
family history I was thinking the other
day that my grandfather made a mistake
with my father on the farm that I am
determined because I can learn from that
not to repeat with my own son on the
farm and then there's of course the
broader cultural history which is why I
believe and I think you win it you and I
share this view we ought to learn from
our history we ought to learn from the
horrors of collectivism in Soviet Russia
we ought to be honest about it we should
teach our young people at the same time
as we're honest about the what's in our
own cultural history but we're also
honest about the nobility for example
the mighty push to abolish slavery
surely the greatest human rights
movement of all times we ought to know
about it it's Noble it was led by noble
people who struggled against
extraordinary odds for a long time yes
exactly and slavery was a human
Universal so it's an it's an amazing
miraculous attainment it's it's a
miraculous attainment absolutely and you
know what we're supposed to be doing in
the Universities is separating the wheat
from the chaff not dispensing with
everything as if it's chaff
because we don't want to put in the
effort to discriminate and so it's
easier well it's just all corrupt it's
like no it's not people aren't starving
to death any
more and societies are increasingly free
and children are dying in the massive
numbers that they once died in and
people are people's life expectancy has
doubled like things are going pretty
well don't muck it up and we need to
figure out why and we need to take stock
of the things that we did in the past
that were wrong obviously but that
doesn't mean that everything everyone
did in the past was wrong that's that
that's not thinking that's just that's
just reflexive resentment masquerading
as intellectual superiority there's
nothing about it that's good when you've
been incredibly generous with your time
can we wrap up let's just think through
what would we say in terms of people
looking for solutions in academia in the
media in politics how do we if you like
start the movement to reclaim what you
called evidence based empirical decision
evidence in decision-making in other
words learn to think again and stop
being us so so emotional there's a place
for emotion but there's a place for
thinking I think well I mean if you're a
university student the first thing you
want to note is that you're there to
learn to think and to write and to read
and to speak that's what you're there to
do and the reason you're there to do
that is because that makes you
incredibly confident because you're
going to have to communicate with people
for the rest of your life and if your
communication has depth and clarity then
you can see your way forward and you can
bring other people aboard and you can do
great things and so it's super it's
super useful to get a real liberal arts
education because it can make you into a
great communicator and thinker if you're
going to university read the great books
and you can you can find professors who
will teach you that but that's what
you're there to do you're there to spend
four years immersing yourself in the
imitation of the greatest people that
our culture has produced and if you
think well there were no great people
well then you might as well not go to
university because University is the
storehouse of the thoughts of great
people and if you dispense with a whole
notion notion of great
then maybe you're there too
I'm a political activist but that's not
university that's something else that's
like an ideological cult and maybe
that's what you want and and and I mean
you know you'll pay the price for that
one way or the other but you even
there's a university student you have to
take on the burden of educating yourself
to large degree but you have to decide
that that's what you want and that's
what you need in terms of your own
personal life um I have a program that I
developed with my colleagues called the
Future authoring program
it's itself authoring calm and it helps
people develop a vision for their life
along about six fundamental dimensions
family education mental and physical
health career avoidance of temptation
like drug and alcohol use we tried to
parse out our use of time you productive
and meaningful use of time outside of
work we tried to parameterize a decent
life and then to guide people through
the process of imagining what their life
could be like if they put it together
properly and you need to develop a
vision for your life and a sense of who
you could be if you were the character
that you could be and and thinking
through that and articulating it is
they're actually part of it should be
part of a classic liberal arts education
because the whole point of Education
apart from the technical end which is
important is to produce a noble citizen
that's the point not to produce a bloody
political activist well then you just
wish would keep in mind that cuz even a
Chatswood that not a lot of those people
most of them are not at university so
they're not excluded either from in any
way shape or form from broadening their
horizon it's not like they're not doing
important things like working men for
example working people in general I
don't care what they're doing if they're
working at a diner as a waiter they're
there they're laying bricks or what
working a forklift or they're plumbers
or these people are bloody important
they build the infrastructure and
there's a huge difference between a a
craftsman who takes pride and caring
what he's doing and contributes to his
family and the community in that
nobility of work and someone who does
shot in half hazard job there's great
nobility in genuine work so and and I
believe that you have just as much power
let's say much as much authority as much
clout as a forthright and honest working
person as you do as an intellectual and
I mean you can be very successful as a
working person if you if you're diligent
and honest and committed and competent
and aiming up because it look I do
believe that each person is the center
of the world and you have what you need
right at that Center and maybe you're
not intellectual but you're good with
your hands and you're practical and
solid and people can rely on you it's
like man that's a big deal because then
when their roof blows off in the middle
of a storm they can call you up and
you're there in an hour and you put the
damn thing back together and and and
hooray for you it's a all of these
things are important and so there's
great nobility in working class work as
far as I'm concerned well Jordan that's
again a fascinating conversation from my
perspective and it's tremendous to be
able to interact with somebody who cares
passionately because that's what that's
what they're picking up I know it's not
about you you're actually trying to make
a difference for people and you know
we're seeing this I'm really disturbed
by the way in which some of these
movements were seeing at the moment of
trying to divide men from women and a
lot of people getting men are getting
this idea that somehow their masculinity
is toxic well you know we don't say that
when the brave young French policeman
takes a bullet for a young woman and her
daughter in a French supermarket we
celebrate that and I actually think that
not all but the great majority of men
want to be Noble they know their flaws
as you said they've got to be honest
about them we all need to be honest but
they also have a big part of them if you
like that divine spike so does aspire
divine spark that leads them to want to
be responsible noble people yes and
that's that's what women want for men do
so unless and as they've been damaged in
their relationship so that they don't
trust men at all and then ours are
prepared to dispense with all of them
which isn't helpful but you know men and
women need to call to the nobility in
each other and that is what they both
want because you want a stalwart
companion by your side know if you're a
man you want someone you can trust and
you can rely on it who will help guide
you and and and and care for you and to
care for your children and all of that
and to make a life with and if you're a
woman you want a man that you can rely
on and that's going to help you help you
deal with the children and with the
excess fragility that you have because
of your pronounced role in reproduction
and that is what we want and to
denigrate a displayed men and women
apart is is to damage humanity itself
because it's not like we're all men are
all women I have sisters and a mother
and a wife it's a daughter and women
have husbands and sons and fathers we're
not separate and just split us apart on
on the basis of sex as well it's it's
it's as pathological as a suicidal
impulse or a murderous impulse or a
genocide linville's
none of that's good it's not acceptable
but we're a hell of a lot better off
than we were and things are getting
better and we can do better yet that's a
way better story we look forward very
much to having you back on those shores
very nice speaking with you again and
thank you very much for the opportunity
thanks Jordan
[Music]
you